this table gives us a few values of the
function G so we know what G of X is
equal to at these values right over here
X is equal to negative 2 negative 1 0 &
1 it says Rafael said that since G of 1
minus G of 0 over 1 minus 0 is equal to
negative 5 there must be a number C in
the interval in the closed interval from
0 to 1 for which G prime of C is equal
to negative 5 which condition makes
Rafael's claim true and they give us 4
choices here so I encourage you to pause
this video and try to work through it on
your own all right before we even look
at these choices let's just revisit
what's going on over here
so Rafael is saying since this so he's
looking at G of 1 minus G of 0 so this
is G of 1 minus G of 0 that's this right
over here over 1 minus 0 over 1 minus 0
so what is this this is this right over
here is the average average rate of
change rate of change between between x
equals 0 and X is equal to 1 another way
to think about it this is the slope of
the line that connects the point 0 comma
8 to the point 1 comma 3 and that
average rate of change is negative 5 and
that he's saying there must be a number
C in the interval in the closed interval
from 0 to 1 for which the derivative of
that X value when X is equal to C is the
same thing as this average rate of
change so this is what the mean value
theorem is all about it's this notion
that like we plot it a little bit just
as a bit of a review so we're going from
0 comma 8 which is maybe right over here
to 1 comma 3 so that's 1 1 comma 3 might
look something like this
so we're seeing the average rate of
change the slope of the line that
connects those two
point is like this what the mean value
theorem tells us if we have the
conditions for the mean value theorem
that let's say that our function does
something like this as long as our
functions meet the conditions of the
mean value theorem which essentially has
to be differentiable over the open
interval and continuous over the closed
interval then there has to be a point C
where the slope of the tangent line at
Point C is equal to the average rate of
change so over here the slope of the
tangent line looks the same as our
average rate of change right over there
just like that so this is the mean value
theorem but we in order to make this
claim that there in order to apply the
mean value theorem to say there must be
a C in the interval where the slope of
the tangent line is X equal C is the
same as the average rate of change we
have to feel very confident that we are
meeting the conditions for the mean
value theorem namely that the function
is continuous over the closed interval
and differentiable over the open
interval from 0 to 1 so let's look at
the choices now G is continuous at x
equals 0 and x equals 1 well that by
itself isn't sufficient we also have to
be continuous at all the points in
between so that by alone does not make
his claim true G is continuous over the
closed interval from 0 to 1 so that's
nice but that doesn't ensure that we're
differentiable over the open interval
from 0 to 1 we have to be continuous and
defriend
there to be continuous over the closed
interval and differentiable over the
over the open interval so we can rule
that one out that's not enough G is
differentiable over the open interval
from negative 1 to 1 and so that
includes this right over here includes
includes the open interval that we care
about this includes the open interval
from 0 to 1 that's what we care about so
that is a check that we're
differentiable over the open interval
and continuous over the closed interval
from negative 1 to 1
well once again this includes the closed
interval that we care about this
includes the closed interval from 0 to 1
and so this is looking good what we care
about is that we're differentiable over
this interval
and for differentiable here we're
definitely differentiable here and that
we're continuous over this interval so I
like this choice this right over here
says G is differentiable over the open
interval and at X is equal to zero so
this is getting us close because if you
are differentiable you are continuous so
one way to interpret this is that we are
differentiable over the interval that is
from zero to one that includes the point
zero now this is close if they said that
we are differentiable 4 over the closed
interval from 0 to 1 that actually would
have been sufficient because if you are
differentiable than you are also
continuous but they did not say that so
we can rule this one out as well we
would have to know this last choice
still does not make us confident that we
are continuous at the point 1 that's
what being continuous over the closed
interval would have told us let's do one
more example that's a little bit
different than this one so here we are
told that G is a differentiable function
once again they've given us the function
sampled at some values of x max was
asked whether there's a solution to G
prime of X is equal to 2 over on the
interval so on the closed interval from
3 to 6 and so we see three here we see
three here so we want to care about the
closed interval from 3 to 6 so the first
thing he did he says ok let's find the
average rate of change from x equals 3
to x equals 6 so this is our change in
our function so G of 6 minus G of 3 over
6 minus 3 LLC G of 6 is equal to 1 G of
3 is equal to negative 5 this is 3 1
minus negative 5 over 3 that's 6 over 3
it is indeed equal to 2 so that step
makes sense the reason I'm going to it
they say is Max's work correct it's not
what it's his mistake so let's look at
step two the mean value theorem so Max
is now saying okay I found the average
rate of change between x equals 3 and x
equals 6 and then he says the mean value
theorem guarantees a solution where G
prime of x equals 2 on this interval so
we have to be careful here because he
just immediately applies the mean value
theorem without establishing the
conditions for the mean value theorem so
I would say even though it does say that
we're differentiable over it I would
make it
I think his mistake is that he did not
make this clear he should have said his
step two should have been something like
because G is differentiable
differentiable over or it sounds like
it's a differentiable function so we
could say for all X it's differentiable
for all X we can say the mean value
theorem the mean value theorem applies
over this interval if you wanted to be
really careful you could said because G
is differentiable for all X is
definitely differentiable over this
closed interval and if it's
differentiable over the closed interval
it's also continuous over the closed
interval and so the mean value theorem
definitely applies and then say the mean
value theorem guarantees a solution so
the reason why it's important to stress
is if you're taking a test especially
things like the AP exam they definitely
if you're going to apply one of these
really any theorems they're going to
want you to put down all the conditions
for the theorem to ensure that you can
apply it as part of your argument